so after we rock climb you guys already
know that we have to eat some bomb-ass
food now one of the things that la is
known for is Mexican food specifically
our street tacos now if you go to
anywhere else and they try to sell your
street tacos for above $1 that means
you're definitely and nowhere near la
this is a taco stand that we personally
love very much called Avenue 26 tacos if
you guys want to know where it's at it's
on Avenue 26 if you guys want to get the
best Mexican Street tacos in LA come to
this spot and you might see me here just
taking them out of business so if you
notice in LA generally if you're gonna
go to one of these taco stands you got
to go to the most ghetto as places above
the more ghetto it is the more delicious
it is it's it's kind of like secluded in
this like one my shrimp is a dead end I
think it's a dead end area it's one of
those late-night taco joints that you
want to go to after you go clubbing or
drinking or you're just hungry in
general
so in LA when you go to these late-night
taco joints you have a couple of options
right so you have either the food truck
or you have the Avenue 26 type taco
stands which basically is just that it's
a taco stand it's open-air those ones
are my personal favors I don't know I
don't have anything against like the
actual taco truck because you know it's
an enclosed space and I think like a
majority of these taco stands eventually
upgrade to that but I kind of like the
authenticity of it it reminds me of a
very Mexico esque when you guys come
here you will see this dude that flips
the [ __ ] out of these tortillas if you
ever go on Facebook you'll see people
like these chefs that do crazy things
all across the world there's this guy
that makes like crazy cotton candy and
[ __ ] but over here we have the ultimate
Mexican tortilla flippers its dopest
[ __ ] we always give them a round of
applause after to a flip those tortillas
as fast as I can
i'ma forearms are dead when you go to
Avenue 26 tacos you get to see
everything prepared you see like the hot
the hot skillet and then cooking it and
it's prepared and it's like chopped up
into bins so we got all of our tacos
generally I don't think anybody knows
what the hell they got this right here
is one of the best cheapest real that
you get in LA
can't beat this if you don't have this
in your city I feel sorry for you what's
your favorite uncle Gary I don't want to
talk about it my favorite sauce is to
get here if you guys want to build the
ultimate taco you have to get the
tomatillo I think it's a tomatillo and
they mix it with like avocado in it it's
so good it's less spicy but it's a
little creamy but you need a little bit
of that acidity with these tacos because
those meats are very fatty they are
cooked and lard that acidity from the
tomatillo and then from the lime and
then also that crunch that you get from
the white onions and also cilantro or
something that you're going to need a
lot just to make sure that you can break
through all that back occasionally now
and then I'll throw in a nice radish to
kind of clean friends my palate but
other than that I keep them really
simple and clean if I eat too many raw
onions gives me bubble guts Hey this
right here is the cabeza which is the
head of the cow head meat
you don't know what you're missing now
this is so [ __ ] delicious
it's not about expensive eats it's about
good eats now I know that you can get
your authentic Mexican food more close
to San Diego as well but the prices
can't be beat and it's just one of those
things that's amazing about Ellen I call
it delicious cheap eats and and these
taco stands represent that to the max
for me when I first came here I was kind
of surprised how cheap they were but
that's that's just a part of I think la
food culture you don't have to break
your bank to have amazing food and you
know I don't really like using that word
authentic because you know authentic to
everybody is very relative but if I were
to use that word authentic for Mexican
tacos or street food that I personally
had in Mexico when I when I went to when
I was younger this reminds me a lot of
it so this right here a lot of you guys
may or may not like this depending if
you guys like that gamey like low fall
taste it's a three part which is the
intestines I generally don't like
intestine since I might Amish [ __ ] but
over here delicious
so you'll see always at the end of these
these tacos or the street taco carts
you'll see these huge this huge round
cooking vessel and in that is actually
lard and the fat from the meat that's
cooking and it'll give it this nice like
crunchy exterior and actually the
potatoes that I ate or cooked in that
lard as well that's that lard cook
potato I was talking about they did use
red potatoes today but what do you think
about the potato kinda has like they
took it really well where it almost has
like a mashed potato type of feel to it
the texture Dan why she lives right in
from the corner told me about this place
and ever since I had it I just went I
had a little chub
just a little yep a phoner
I sexually harass some tacos I think
Bonnie had a like 11 or 12 tacos I think
she matched my taco intake which is
insane
both of them weigh as much as one of my
thighs and they could eat as much as I
can maybe be more i total at 11:11 time
yeah you know what the weird thing is
like when I look at people that skinny
and they eat that much
I just how much do they poop is that
weird because whenever I eat food like
for example I'll need like a burger
right and then when I [ __ ] a tic-tac
comes out where did the food go you can
get a taco dang taco dance garrick taco
dance
Oh
if you guys ever had the chance to meet
Bonnie and Sonny you will realize how
insane these girls are their
personalities are as live as it gets
now I'm a very energetic person they
tire me out a lot I can only imagine
what it's like spending a week with them
they are excitable human beings but I
kind of love it at the same time because
their energy gives me energy I think we
have multiple videos of beats working
actually fraternal twins yeah the funny
thing is I couldn't really tell them
apart
I don't know why maybe it's cuz their
personality are very similar but if you
guys want to know how to tell them apart
the best just by the hair color sunny
sunny hair Bonnie
blood-red I can't tell you how much I
love Mexican Street tacos it's like this
[ __ ] I think that whole meal for
everybody cost 37 dollars I just spent
six people till they were like full to
the brim actually a little more because
I had more tacos but but um yeah man and
don't be afraid to try those different
means to I know a lot of you guys are
used to like asada which is just the
beef but try out the treatment try to
butch it try some of the al past or the
pork you'll like it
remember goodies all about goodies